are you alive we want more videos oh
it's just a dream I really got to make
some videos right after I take a little
nap we want more videos Rob and can you
fix my front tooth please ah hey what's
going on guys I'm back and it's
definitely time to get another haircut
so let's take care of that first alright
now that that's done there's just a few
things that I wanted to update you guys
on I know I haven't put any videos out
for the last two months and this seems
to be a recurring theme in my videos
that I keep on saying that but I have
been busy with school and other things
of course I get the obligatory are you
dead comments well as you could plainly
see no good the comments are getting a
little bit old and you guys should
really come up with something new like
did you get hit by a bus or did your
evil kitty kill you with the laser Oh
actually let's stay away from the death
stuff and come up with something a
little bit more unique like Rob fell
into the toilet and flushed himself land
up on the other side of the world and
had to walk back you get the point if
you come up with a good one you can
leave your interesting or creative
responses in the comments section Rob
yeah who's calling me it's PETA you're
not raywilliamjohnson I'm not no people
told me I look like him no you don't
just stopping whatever you happy the
good news is that I'm pretty much done
with my first two years of dental school
which means I should have more free time
now to make some videos it also means
that I'm officially a student doctor and
I could work on real patients instead of
fake teeth so torn sole make a super
master anyone else out there who really
wants to be my patient if you're in the
local philadelphia area
send me a message and maybe we could set
something up one thing I wanted to do in
this video was to talk about the contest
that I held about two months ago after
the tsunami in Japan the students
rebuild org website opened up a Facebook
group call
paper cranes for Japan they were
accepting paper cranes to be sent into
the group and paying out $2 for every
crane that was sent into the Japan
relief efforts initially their goal was
set at a hundred thousand copies that
the group got they had to raise their
goal to a million cranes and they
eventually paid out a million dollars
and I think that deserves a huge round
of applause that's really incredible
I held a contest on my channel to see
who could fold the most cranes and I
also had certain rules like you had to
put them in groups of five you had to
count them all out those are the two big
ones that I was really looking for when
I was looking in the video I also said
that you had to say hey Rob these are
the paper cranes I fold it for Japan
didn't really matter I'm not going to be
picky with all the videos you know if
you didn't say it precisely or anything
like that I also had some questions from
people saying well how do I know that
ten people didn't work together on this
and fold you know a thousand cranes or
whatever so I was also looking for
basically one person who had folded the
cranes all of you guys did an amazing
job I watched through every single video
response I commented on every single one
and I also liked every single one and I
just like to say you guys also deserve a
huge round of applause the video showing
and counting the most cranes and also
abiding by the rules that I had set was
by viewer named Adams adventures she
started folding a thousand paper cranes
for her bucket list and when she found
out about the paper cranes for Japan
cause she joined in and folded 226
cranes and counted them on video Hey
okay so this is my video showcasing all
the paper cranes I've built so far all
right so here's a little video of all
the cranes that I have on my bed I'll
just begin counting beach set um 1 2 3
41 42 43 44 45 and that's one extra that
I had leftover great job - Adam I hope
I'm pronouncing her name right she did
fold and count the most on video I've
featured her video which is linked below
on my channel and it already has over a
thousand views the video with the next
highest amount of cranes was by Shadow
Darkrai 1 2 3 and he folded 205 total
hello this is shadow dark 1 2 3 and
these are all my 205 paper cranes
Japan in the background you can see a
Pikachu Amy hello to Japan I will now
start out by counting all my paper
cranes 10 20 30 Andy 200 205 Japan these
are all my paper cranes and I wish you
good luck and please continue doing my
Pokemon sure he was out really late at
night working on this video cuz he was
wearing his pajamas
great job shadow dark try 1 2 3 and I
wouldn't worry about your Pokemon I'm
sure they're still going to continue to
make it one response that I thought was
very original was by a ninja girl 101
she folded 86 cranes in all and she was
also the first as far as I'm aware to
form a Japanese flag out of the paper
cranes
and see I also need Japan why I got a
praise she also wrote on the paper
cranes things such as Thousand Cranes
for Japan will a fire for Japan and also
care for Japan Japan will a fire help
Japan and care for Japan great job Kanan
you go 101 here I have a hat that has
the remaining twenty something people
who had submitted video responses I'm
going to mix it up I'm not looking not
looking mix it up a little bit more and
the first video response is going to be
from Bob 3 the next one is going to be
from
speed cubing videos genius pop three
folded 131 paper cranes although in his
video we accidentally counted 136 penis
pop three here and these are the paper
creams I made for Japan 5 10 30 135 and
then 136 at the end of the video he also
arranged the cranes to look like a
Japanese flag thank you very much for
submitting the video genius part 3 the
last video response was by speed cubing
videos and what I thought was pretty
funny about it was that like I said in
my contest video you know you don't have
to put them all over your room you can
put them into groups of 5 but he did
arrange them all over his room hey
everybody this is speed cubing videos
and this is my entry to the paper cranes
contest I have him all the cranes
grouped in groups of 5 as you can see he
even had a couple of them that he pulled
out of his desk drawer see 6570 great
job and thank you very much for
submitting the video speed cubing videos
and I said I would give you guys
high-five so you know I guess if I have
to do multiple ones I'm gonna have to do
it with two hands so let's try this out
okay high-five assault I really wish
that I could have featured every single
one they were all awesome I tried to
make it as fair as I could to get as
many people featured but don't feel bad
if you didn't get selected I'm going to
have more contests and giveaways in the
future giving away some cubes maybe even
like a gift card or an iPod Touch or
different types of origami models that
I've made so definitely be sure to
subscribe if you're not already so that
you know when I come out with the new
videos and I promise that I won't take
two months to let you guys know who won
I had been reading my comments and
messages and I know that a lot of people
really want to see the origami magic
ball all I see on my videos is a to
Oregon magic ball we want to see the
magic ball I get that you want to see
the magic ball this is the closest that
I've ever come to making one it's not
the real right way to do it it only has
half the amount of folds I'm trying to
get better at it so that yes I might be
able to teach you guys how to make this
in the future I finally got a new phone
I wound up getting the iPhone 4 it's
really great the one thing that I really
liked about it was the video and so I
decided to strap it to my kite and fly
it hope you make it back that's actually
my buddy rich he does have a youtube
channel at
choose method you can check it out by
clicking here all right yeah and that's
my friend unki and his ninja bicycle
shirt call me crazy but I think it was
definitely worth it because I'm able to
take video with my phone I decided to
try to create a new channel called Rob's
phone you can click on it there's
nothing really there now but I am
thinking of doing some vlog videos with
the phone while I'm in school during the
day stuff like that my friend from
college who's also on YouTube he's about
to break 50000 subscribers you can check
him out at the portrait art I asked him
to do a portrait and also a speed
drawing video of me and he sent it to me
so I'm thinking of putting that on my
channel soon also thank you all again
for watching commenting and subscribing
I'll be sure to see you soon and here
are some of the paper crane for Japan
comments that I got on the last video